what I want to do in this video is
explore differences in times or another
way to think about it is how much time
passes between two different times and
to make that concrete let's say that I
start watching a movie at 1:00 at 1:25
p.m. and let's say that the movie
finishes the movie finishes at 3:16 p.m.
so how long can how do we figure out how
long that movie was so it starts at 1:25
p.m. and it ends at 3:16 and there's a
couple of ways to do this one I'll do it
with the number line which is kind of
the slower way but it's easier to
visualize then I'll show you a slightly
faster way to do it and then we'll think
about how do we figure how do we think
about it if one of them is a.m. and then
the other one is p.m. so let's just
think about it one step at a time so let
me just draw a little I guess we could
call it a time line so if this right
here is 1:25 p.m. 1:25 p.m. and that
this right over here is 3 3/16 p.m. so
what I do when I think about it this way
is I say okay well how many minutes do I
have to get to the next whole hour and
if I'm at 1:25 it takes 35 minutes to
get to the next whole hour so if you
give me 35 minutes so this is 35 35
minutes that gets me to 2 o'clock and
then if you give me another hour that
gets me to 3 o'clock so if you get me
another hour that gets me to 3 o'clock
and so this is one hour one hour and
then you give me another 16 minutes that
gets me to 3 16 so 16 minutes so the
total amount of time that passed is
going to be 1 hour plus 35 minutes plus
16 minutes so what's that so 35 plus 16
I'll do it right over here 35 plus 16 5
plus 6 is 11 1 plus three is four plus
one is five so it's 51 minutes so it's
one hour and then 51 minutes right 35
minutes plus 16 minutes is 51 so we get
one hour one hour and 51 and 51 and 51
minutes now what is another way to do
this and this way is pretty analogous to
when we just subtract numbers I mean we
do a little bit of borrowing but the or
grouping but the borrowing or the
regrouping is different if I said that
we started at 2 p.m. and finished at 3
p.m. you would just say ok 3 minus 2 is
equal to 1 or if I said we started at 1
p.m. and we finished at 9 p.m. you just
say ok 9 p.m. - 1 p.m. is equal to 8
hours but the problem here is we have
some we have minutes along with the
hours and it gets a little confusing
because there's there's 60 minutes to an
hour and all of that and that's what
we're going to do a little bit of a I
guess you could call it a borrowing
trick so what you say is let's subtract
125 from 316 but we have to keep in our
mind that we're dealing with times here
so we're going to subtract so we're
going to subtract 1 hour and 25 minutes
from 316 and we can do this right now
because we're both taught we're talking
about p.m. in either case what we're
going to see in future video or maybe
later in this video is if one of them is
a.m. or one of them is p.m. is probably
good to convert them both to military
time and we can think about that in the
next video but lists in just this
situation how do we subtract 125 from
316 so let's try it out so like all
subtraction you see you try to see if
the numbers in above that you're
subtracting from are larger than the
numbers that you're taking away from
those numbers 6 is larger than 5 so
we're cool there 1 is not larger than 2
so we want to borrow or we want to
regroup and we want to borrow from the 3
right over here remember this is 3 hours
so if we were to borrow one of those
hours instead of 3 hours we now have 2
hours here what can I add to this one so
when you do traditional borrowing since
every place is 10 times the previous
place you would add 10 to this place but
since we're talking about hours and
minutes so this is the 10-minute spot
right this is the one-minute spot this
is the 10-minute spot if you take away
one hour you get 6 10-minute spots
so what you do is you add 6 to this spot
right over here so you add 6 so if your
tip if you're borrowing from the hours
and giving it to the tens or the ten
spots of the minutes then you'll add 6
so you'll add 6 actually it should be a
6 we're going to add 6 so it's 1 plus 6
is 7 and now we can subtract we have 6
minus 5 is 1 7 minus 2 is 5
that's our minutes and then 2 minus 1 2
minus 1 is 1 and we're done we're it
we're 1 hour and 51 minutes so you
didn't have to completely visualize it
this way although this is a little bit
more intuitive let's do one that crosses
that crosses the am/pm barrier so let's
say that we are starting let me draw
another another another number line here
so let's say we are starting at 9 let's
say we're starting at 9 9 16 am and we
are going all the way to I'll do it in
the same color let's say we're going all
the way to 10 10 15 10:15 p.m. actually
let me do a slightly different one let's
do 10 10 17 10:17 p.m. so in our
traditional the way we do it visually if
you don't want to convert anything the
military time what we can do in this
situation is to say okay how much time
does it take us to get to noon and then
how much time from noon till 10:17 p.m.
so if we think about how much time it
takes us to get to noon that's one way
to do it so let me draw 12 this is 12
p.m. right over here so it's going to
take 44 minutes to get to 10:00 a.m.
right so this right here is 44 minutes
that's to get to 10:00 a.m. I got 44 by
taking by subtracting 16 from 60 so 44
minutes gets us to 10 a.m. and then
obviously we have another two hours till
noon two hours and then we have 10 hours
and 17 minutes till 10 7
p.m. so now we have and then now this is
10 hours 10 hours and 17 minutes so now
we just add everything up we have 2
hours plus 10 hours which is 12 hours so
with 12 hours and then 17 minutes plus
44 minutes so what's that let me just
add it right over here 44 plus 17 4 plus
7 is 11 4 plus 7s are 4 plus 5 is 4 plus
1 is 5 plus 1 is 6 so we have 12 hours
and 61 minutes which I guess is right
but it's strange to say 61 minutes
because we know this is more than an
hour
so 61 minutes this part we can rewrite
as 1 hour one hour and one minute one
minute and then we could add this hour
to this hour and we get 13 hours 13
hours and one minute now the other way
to do it the other way to do it is we
could do it this way up here where we
essentially subtract the starting time
from the ending time for it but in order
for that to work properly we want to
convert everything to Military dine and
it sounds like a very fancy thing but in
military time anything that is p.m. you
just add 12 hours to it and what the
reason why that makes sense is and the
reason why the military cares about it
is it becomes clear if I tell you if I
tell you that we're going to go at 9
o'clock
it's very unambiguous that the the
project or the whatever the invasion or
whatever will start at 9 a.m. if I
wanted to say 9 p.m. I would add 12 to 9
and I would say we're going to go at
2100 hours it makes it very clear that
that is 9 p.m. so what you do is you
convert both to military time so 916
a.m. is still going to be 916 am 916 am
but 10:17 p.m. we're going to add 12 to
it we're going to add 12 to it and in
military time it'll be 22 22 17 so this
right here is military time military
military time and so we can
tract the starting time from the ending
time now 22:17 and we can subtract and
actually I shouldn't even write the a.m.
here we're talking about military time
so you don't have to differentiate
between a.m. and p.m. here and then we
subtract 7 - it'll look like we have to
do any borrowing here 7 minus 6 is 1 1
minus 1 is 0 then we go into the hours
that we have to do a little bit over
here or we just know what 22 minus 9 is
but let's blitz borrow just so here
we're just borrowing hours from hours so
if we borrow if we borrow if this 2
becomes a 1 where you can add 10 to this
2 right over here so this becomes a 12
12 minus 9 is 3 and then you just bring
down that 1 and we have 13 hours and one
minute so the same result this is a
little bit faster actually a lot faster
you're less likely to make mistake
because you have to do all you don't
have to do all this stuff in your head